mais d'abord on y est un mois et demi
après la fermeture des commerces et plus
de 6 après celle des bars et restaurants
vous allez enfin pouvoir en profiter à
nouveau
première étape demain du déconfinement
pour boire un coup ou manger un morceau
ce sera en terrasse pour l'instant on
croise les doigts pour le temps les
commerçants eux sont dans les starting
blocks le reportage à tours et ses
alentours d'hélène chapelet dans ce bar
tabac de la ville aux dames le service
au comptoir ce n'est pas encore pour
tout de suite dès demain ses tables vont
être installés dehors
quatre grandes tablées séparés pour
accueillir jusqu'à 24 clients maximum en
attendant le rideau reste bc côté bar
heureusement les clients fréquentent
toujours les lieux grâce au tabac presse
mais l'ambiance n'est pas la même le
retour de la terrasse est donc une bonne
nouvelle
merci bien là on ouvre vraiment pour nos
clients pour justement pour leur donner
cette cette envie de revenir et puis
leur donner une petite bouffée d'oxygène
et à nous aussi de pouvoir avoir du dd
jean pouvoir entendre rire entendre
parler enfin ce qu'on aime dans un
marcquois la convivialité tout
simplement
autre lieu même attente dans cette
boutique tourangelle de prêt-à-porter
féminin anne marie se prépare à rouvrir
après un mois et demi d'arrêt elle en
est sûre dès demain la clientèle sera de
retour pour faire à nouveau du shopping
on a la boule au ventre parce qu'il faut
tout remettre au point parce que on
risque d'avoir du monde et j'espère
qu'on va voir du monde que les gens vont
avoir le plaisir de venir nous parler
d'avoir un côté social qu'on a
d'habitude
donc non je crois je crois et je reste
positive demain tout le monde va
travailler
un optimisme qui n'a rien de paroles en
l'air dans la bouche de marie car demain
elle ouvrira une toute nouvelle boutique
toujours à tour dans ce contexte
pourtant si particulier